games walking challenge it's still not
too late to make a new year's resolution
to get active and stay fit and watch
your district council is here to help
the council is taking part in a special
project organizing a series of walks to
help you get fit in the run-up to the
london 2012 olympic and paralympic games
rochford along with castlepoint
southend-on-sea and south east essex
Ramblers has teamed up with the Essex
legacy team at Essex County Council to
bring you walking your way to the games
the challenge is simple there are five
walls to complete around South Essex
they are divided into five colors and
you will receive an essex legacy badge
in the color of the walk to attend the
challenge is can you collect all
possible badges and here are the details
of the walks the shortest walk is the
red walk to be held a Priory Park and is
a distance of one to one and a half
miles the date is yet to be confirmed
but the time will be at 115 p.m. and
you'll meet outside the cafe in priory
park victoria avenue southend-on-sea SS
26 and be the green walk will take place
along can vc wall and is assistance of
one and a half to one or three quarter
miles again the date is to be confirmed
but the time will be 1030am and you meet
at can vc wall the lab with car park ss8
7nq the yellow walk takes place in
hockley woods and is a distance of two
to two-and-a-half miles the date for
this is the twentieth of april and it
begins at port 11 in the morning meet at
the car park in hockley woods ss5 four
are in the blue walk will take place in
hadley and is a distance of four miles
taking place on the twentieth of May at
ten-thirty in the morning and the
meeting point is the Salvation Army car
park and the longest walk for blackboard
takes place in little wakering with the
distance of five miles on during the
eighth beginning at ten in the morning
and the meeting point is little wakering
church additional dates are being
organized later in the in the year and
for more information contact the Sports
Development Officer Mark alders on 0170
2318 one-to-one or email him mark dot
Aldous and that's a LD o us at Rochford
gov UK inspire mark award for district
project Roger District Council's dreams
and memories project has been granted
inspire mark the badge of the London
2012 inspire program the council is one
of only 15 local authorities in the
country to have received funding for the
project which will record local people's
olympic and paralympic memories and
hopes for 2012 before adding them to a
national online archive the London 2012
12 inspire program recognizes innovative
and exceptional projects that are
directly inspired by the 2012 Olympic
and Paralympic Games digital recordings
of opinions will form part of the
project from everyone young or old from
across the district in audio and video
format school children will be taking
part in creative art workshops and
adding their artworks as digital images
to the archive Rochford District
Council's portfolio holder for leisure
tourism heritage the arts culture and
business counselor Keith Gordon said
this ambitious project is a fantastic
way to put brought to it on the map in
the run-up to the London 2012 Olympics
the council is already working hard on a
number
projects as part of our legacy from the
2012 games including the Rochford
district sports awards which last year
welcome Paralympic champion danny crates
as the guest of honor i hope as many
local people as possible come forward
and record their memories for what will
be an interesting and historic project
anybody interested in taking part sub
contact 0170 2546 366 the rockford art
trail for 2012 11 applications are now
open for local artists interested in
taking part in this year's right with
our trail over the course of one week in
October this year a range of artists
will create temporary art exhibitions in
shops businesses and public spaces
around Rochford town the art trail is
arranged in partnership between what two
District Council open arts and ethics
adult community learning and sponsored
by virgin active applications are open
to artists working in the range of
mediums including painting photography
sculpture jewelry and crafts for more
information visit www k ford / art trail
ball contact Roxie curry the arts
development officer on 0 1 702 318 171
the 2011 census every 10 years the
office for national statistics ons
carries out a sensors to find out more
about the people who live in England and
Wales and about the makeup of local
neighborhoods the census asks about work
health national identity citizenship
ethnic background education second homes
language religion marital status and so
on these statistics are then used to
build a picture of today's society like
all local authorities in England and
Wales rot the district council relies on
census population statistics to get the
government funding we need for public
services how much we get is directly
related to how many and what kind of
people the census says live in our area
so even if the census were to end up
just a few households short it could
make a very real difference to people's
lives the sensors needs to include
everyone everywhere and that's why
everyone has to take part and what you
need to do well simple just answer a few
questions about yourself and the people
who share your household with you on
census day which was the 27th of March
everything you tell the census is in
strictest confidence and will only be
used to produce statistics the ONS will
not share your personal information with
any other government department or
organization you can do it online you
can do it by closed but you must do it
so get your questionnaire back as soon
as possible a census needs everyone to
take part in helping tomorrow take shape
and this is your chance to make a
difference for more information visit
www.initialunderwriting.org
eating their census form and there are
two slots remaining on Tuesday the fifth
of April between 10am and 4pm at
Rochford council offices and on
Wednesday the sixth of April between
10am and 4pm at raley council offices
you said we did the budget survey last
year Rochford district council launched
a consultation to find out which of the
services we provide are most important
to you tackling anti-social behavior and
environmental crime waste & Recycling
street cleaning and lissa picking were
identified as the most important
services the areas where residents
wanted to reduce spending worth car
parks sports culture and leisure and
parks and open spaces the budget survey
asking residents to prioritize council
services in terms of their importance
and whether spending should be reduced
or increased was published in the last
two editions of Rochford district
matters and made available online on the
council's website copies of the survey
were also distributed at various council
meetings and venues in order to get as
many responses as possible but also
received a total of 350 responses 220 by
post and 130 online the feedback from
this consultation has been considered by
members during the budget process and
some of the budgetary decisions are in
line with the consultation responses
including reducing the cost of woodlands
and protecting waste and recycling
services street cleaning and community
safety the council has put in place
plans to deliver cost reductions of
approximately 1.4 million pounds in
2011-12 and has agreed to freeze its
council tax the leader of Rochford
District Council Councillor Terry
cutmore said the relatively low number
of responses could indicate that our
residents trust us to take the right
decisions on the big issues everyone at
watch the district council works hard to
ensure we do the best we can for our
residents and we think we have offered
them a budget that is fair and balanced
I'd like to thank everyone who took part
in the consultation the responses
provided a useful guide as to the
relative importance that people place on
each service area and was invaluable to
members during the budget setting
process
watch the district council tax for the
financial year 8 4 2011 to March 2012
has been frozen in addition Essex County
Fire and Rescue Authority Essex Police
Authority and Essex County Council have
also frozen their parts of the overall
tax bill of your total council tax bill
only thirteen percent comes through
Oxford District Council with the rest
going to Essex County Council
seventy-two percent Essex County Fire
and Rescue Authority four percent as its
Police Authority nine percent and the
parish town councils two percent more
information is included in the booklet
which accompanies your council tax bill
or visit our website www k and how the
council services are funded from
government grant 25 point three million
pounds fees and charges 4.6 million
pounds and council tax 6.4 million
pounds
how we will be saving money our plan for
the coming year the government has set
out the toughest local government
finance settlement in living memory
which is resulting in widespread
reductions in government funding to
local authorities this year Rochford's
grant was reduced this year to 3.6 five
million pound the Tulsa will also
receive 159 thousand pound towards the
council tax freeze to put this into
perspective delivery of statutory
services alone is estimated to cost 9.7
million pound for 2011-12 this means
that the council has a budget gap of
twelve percent of its total budget and
this has meant that the council has had
to take some tough decisions in order to
close this gap some of the key areas for
reducing spend will be reducing the
budget for members allowances for
2011-12 reducing the salary bill through
voluntary redundancies reductions in
hours and career breaks and an
organisational restructure to reduce the
size of the senior management team
removing budgets for taxi vouchers
handyperson and handy gardening services
reducing the overall running costs of
the gull councils accommodation looking
at alternative management arrangements
for the Great Wakering leisure centres
including the potential transfer of
ownership reviewing car parking policies
and practices although the council is
reducing the amount paid out to the
voluntary sector it has maintained a
budget of 90,000 pound and will continue
to support the voluntary sector through
our staff volunteers scheme payroll
givers you earn and providing access to
information about other sources of
funding in its corporate plan the
council identifies what it needs to
deliver for the whole community
our main focus for the year ahead will
be to deliver our target savings while
continuing to improve service access and
delivery to our community progress the
joint area action plan in partnership
with Southend Borough Council covering
london Southend Airport and environments
progress the area action plans for the
town centres of hotly ruptured and
rayleigh work in partnership to develop
and improve so as provision to our
communities continuing to improve
customer facilities and access of the
Cherry Orchard jubilee country park and
secure the delivery of new homes
including afford all housing
you